did you know that when The Simpsons
first made its move to digital animation
it spent the first few years using some
pretty wild techniques just to make it
look like it was still old school cell
animation that's right when the show
first moved to digital animation they
were worried that the shift would be too
jarring for audiences at home and so
they cooked up a great deal of tricky
composite work in post to make the
digital animation look like cell
animation Honestly though the lengths
they went to were pretty impressive not
just something basic like adding grain
but more complicated effects like adding
chromatic aberration cell Shadows
textured line art the whole nine yards
they kept this up for a fair few years
too until they slowly weaned off of it
and went with the full-blown digital
aspect that sterile digital look is
definitely one of the many things that
gets hate from Modern Simpsons so I
wonder what it'd be like if they
returned to that faux cell animation
Style